foreign
[Music]
for the past 10 years I've been keeping
this little notebook with a scratch pad
that I call
you see that money wisdom reminders to
self and these are basically just
anytime I heard something I read
something or I learned something that
was wise about wealth I would write it
down and I put all the notes here and
today I'm going to read you a bunch of
the things that are in this notebook and
um you know I feel like I could do that
because in most places you can't really
talk about money money is sort of this
tacky taboo thing you're not supposed to
everybody has to pretend they don't care
about money
but we all do which is weird
um but you know you just have to treat
it like this the silent fart in the room
you gotta pretend pretend you didn't
care about it pretend it's not there uh
but it's there and this channel luckily
is different there's a channel where we
come we talk about business talk about
money you're talking about mindset we
talk about a bunch of different things
that are interesting to us and really
the only people who click on this
channel are people that care about those
things and so it's like when you go to
the gym you can flex and talk about your
pecs because the other people there care
about that sort of stuff and uh so you
know it's understood so this is the
money wisdom Channel I think in the next
15 minutes I don't think this will be
long I'll be able to go through a bunch
of the Nuggets I call Golden nuggets
that I had written down in this so the
first one I'll start with this
the rich aren't just lucky
so pretend we took all the money that
existed and we redistributed it out
everybody got the same you know let's
say a hundred thousand dollars to start
with
ten years later I think that most of the
rich people would be rich again because
wealth building is a skill and it can be
learned
and uh for most people you want to learn
this skill but you don't really know
where to start and I'll give the uh I
write down these sort of three shifts
these big big small shifts that you can
make what is a big small shift so I'll
give you a quick story
um a man wants to learn golf so he goes
out and he buys a you know set of golf
clubs and he goes to the driving range
starts hitting some balls and you know
it's going left it's going right some
are going to the center you can't really
control it doesn't know how to doesn't
know how to do it he just started and um
so he's like okay I need to build this
skill but uh I don't know how you know I
don't know what I'm doing to be honest
and so he sees like you know in the in
the right next to him in the driving
range there's a coach teaching a kid so
he walks over he tells the coach hey I'd
love to learn coach says happy to work
with you first lessons tomorrow morning
okay so he shows up again tomorrow
morning you know this coach teaches them
a few things another coach you know he's
sort of a you know he's maybe 24 years
old he's he himself just graduated from
college you know he's not the best in
the world he's just the guy standing
next to him
um but still it helps
he's hitting it a bit better but not
much the ball's still going left and
right and you know the man thinks to
himself yeah this coach sucks I don't
want this crappy this guy's a kid's
coach I need a real Coach and so he says
you know what I'm gonna hire the best
who is the best coach he goes and finds
a professional golfer to be his coach
this coach gives us some instructions
within a few minutes he's hitting the
ball straight it's going great
um and so he says all right I'm ready to
go play tomorrow I'm playing a full 18
holes of golf let's do this shows up the
next day and he's ready to hit the ball
straight again but today things are
going different today it's slicing left
it's slicing right and he's getting
frustrated and the worst part the thing
that's frustrating him the most is that
the coach's not saying anything he sort
of expects the coach to jump in and fix
it but he coaches just watching
so finally he turns around he says hey
coach are you gonna you're gonna do
something you're just gonna stand there
all right like look at me I'm way off I
gotta do so I gotta change something and
the coach Just Smiles
coach says you know you think you're way
off but you're really only two
millimeters off
he said coach no offense I know you're
the expert here but pretty sure I'm off
by more than two millimeters the ball's
gone 100 yards into the lake here and
the coach says yeah yeah I understand
that the outcome might be far off but
all you you're only off by two
millimeters you just need a two
millimeter shift
you see because when your golf club hits
the ball if it's two millimeters angled
in the wrong direction it will
completely change the trajectory of
where a ball is going right a small
shift in the angle here is going to take
us in a completely different direction
and so he just shows him a couple tweaks
watch where you're where you're hitting
the ball look at the face of the of the
club
so he makes the adjustment takes a swing
Nails it and um you know I heard this
story first from Tony Robbins and um I
don't know I don't know if it's real or
fake or whatever but I love the idea
because it really rang true to me most
things in life
even if you're far off in your outcome
you're actually just only a small shift
in your approach away because that's
what changes your trajectory so here's
the small two millimeter shifts that I
think most people need to make
um this was after all the money wisdom I
collected they all kind of bucketed into
these three shifts that you can make
shift number one
hard work to Smart work
uh growing up we're all pretty much told
hard work is the key to success our
teachers tell us this our parents tell
us this but we gotta ask is this really
true because I look outside I see the
lawn guy mowing the lawn and working in
the summer heat he's working hard or you
go into any restaurant go to the back of
the kitchen look at the line Cooks those
guys are working hard they're working
crazy hours
it's hot out there it's difficult
they're on their feet all day they work
you know Saturdays and Sundays because
the restaurant doesn't stop they work
hard
and you know you start to think about it
like well if hard work equals success
then why doesn't my janitor driving a
Bentley right because what you work on
and who you work with is what matters it
matters a lot more than how hard you
work so again what you work on the thing
you actually choose to do
and who you work with will make a far
bigger impact in your trajectory than
just hard work in fact there is hard
work does help but it's maybe the fifth
or sixth most important factor in my
opinion uh I do think there's sort of a
minimum like you need to work hard
enough but beyond hard enough there's
not really like a maximum you should be
chasing the goal is not to work as hard
as you possibly can okay so what should
you actually work on right I said that's
the most important thing well uh Naval
ravacott says it best he says you want
to find the thing that feels like play
to you and work to others and you should
keep dabbling until you find that
because at first you might say well what
feels like play to me is watching
Netflix okay cool that feels like play
to you but it doesn't look like work to
others and so you have to find the thing
that is play to you work to others for
me for example
it's business stuff so
I am a nerd I love reading about
learning about businesses I like to go
you know if a stock is if a company's
gonna go public I'll go read the S1 I
want to read all about the inner
workings of the business to most people
they see this 100 page PDF it's like
you're digging through to find the
balance sheet or the p l statement for
for what dude you're is your boss
telling you to do this
no I actually enjoy doing that but to
others it would seem like work and so
that's a kind of a sweet spot you want
to identify and really lean into those
types of moments or this podcast some
people get really nervous about public
speaking or it seems like a lot of work
or wow you gotta you gotta come up with
something you know an hour worth of
stuff to say every two days about
business and don't you feel a lot of
pressure no no this feels like play to
me and so if it feels like work to
others but it feels like play to you
those are the That's The Sweet Spot
that's what you're looking for
for some people that's programming
programming could be you know a joy to
some people and it's a pain to others
for some people it's writing like I love
writing other people hate writing they
think writing is just they still have
Trauma from school they can't stand
writing
um you know for my trainer it's exercise
after he trains me and you know four
other people he's been in the gym for
six hours straight where does he go when
he's done to the gym because he wants to
get his workout in it's crazy like that
you know for him exercise and being in
the gym feels like play whereas to
others it would feel exhausting it feel
like work hell Marie condo loves
cleaning she made that her thing she
loves cleaning uh but that feels like
work to me and many others so
you gotta find that thing uh why does
this matter because when it feels like
play you'll do it a lot not just nine to
five you'll do it from five to nine too
you'll just do it all the time any
available moment you have your brain
will go in that direction because it's
something you enjoy doing so much and
because you enjoy doing it you'll keep
doing it you can do it for a long period
of time even if you're not getting
immediate results right there's many
things that we will do if we get
immediate results it's the things you're
willing to do even without immediate
results that lead to these big wins in
the end and uh you know you know what
they call the guy who practices all the
time and never gives up right so
somebody who does it all the time and
can do it for for a long period of time
the best that's what they call the guy
they call him the best and the best
always gets paid in any field the best
plumber gets paid the best then he gets
paid the best whatever you are gets paid
and so you want to find the thing that
feels like play to you because it will
help you become the best
shift number two so we've gone from hard
work to Smart work and that's finding
the thing that feels like play to you
and work to others now shift number two
is
you want to go from being far away from
money to hanging out with money
so let's pretend you want to get a
six-pack
to get a six-pack to get abs you need to
start thinking and acting like somebody
who already has a six-pack right like
they make certain choices about how they
eat they make certain choices about with
like you know if you travel with
somebody who's fit they got in their
bags and protein powder resistance bands
they'll pick a hotel based on the gym
they make decisions you don't make
because they have a certain set of
priorities and habits that you don't
have so you got to sort of think like a
fit person to act like a fit person then
you become a fit person same goes for
wealth you gotta think like a wealthy
person act like a wealthy person and
then you become a wealthy person most
people get this wrong they laugh about
this like oh so I should just that guy
Rich guys by you know Ferrari so I
should go buy Ferrari
not really you want to find their habits
not their extravagances right not their
indulgences you want to find their
habits you want to hang around with them
so that you understand what their habits
are the small things they do on a
day-to-day basis that make them who they
are and you need to start doing them so
you need to shift your way of thinking
to match the type of person that you
want to become all right so how do you
how do you start thinking like a wealthy
person well you got to hang out with
them but how do you hang out with them
right like um
you know you they may not be around you
you know what if you don't know anybody
so there's three ways the first is peers
so you want to find you know five people
with the same dream as you right do you
know five people who have the same dream
as you who are taking it as seriously as
you or more seriously you want to find
those people you need to create a group
chat you need to create a weekly dinner
hell move into a house together do
whatever it takes when I wanted to get
good at poker I literally lived with a
bunch of other people who are trying to
get good at poker and all day we're all
playing poker we're all talking poker
over our meals we're thinking about
poker we're asking each other for
questions we're getting inspired by
somebody else's success we're getting
bitter about that guy's success but it
makes us work harder you want to immerse
yourself in an immersive environment
where you're going to get better and so
get as close to it as you can living
together is the best if you can't do
living together
get dinners together if you get dinners
you're getting a group chat together do
whatever it takes
um the second one is mentors so you got
your peers now you want your mentors
this is somebody who's already done it
you can learn from them the trick here
is really simple what most people do
wrong is they go and ask for you to be
their Mentor here's what you actually
want to do you want to find somebody
who's already done it you want to ask
them a specific question
hey I'm dealing with this situation
right now I needed it I need to decide
between A and B here's what I'm thinking
um
could you give me any uh you know advice
on this decision between A and B how
would you think about this then whatever
they say you go take Massive Action on
it and then you follow up you say hey
you tell me that thing here's how here's
what happened you know it either really
worked or really didn't work here's what
I'm doing next is you repeat it you do
that three times with somebody they're
kind of informally your Mentor anyways
you never need to ask them to sort of
like you know be in a relationship with
you it'll just happen naturally by being
somebody who asks to ask specific
questions so don't ask them for their
time ask them for their specific advice
then actually take action on it and then
the key follow up if you repeat that
you'll have mentors
okay the next way you hang out with
money you got to change your information
diet so if you're already listening to
this podcast or watching this video on
YouTube
congratulations you're already doing it
but you need to ask people who have
achieved what you want what do you
listen to what do you follow what do you
read uh what are your favorite YouTube
channels uh you know my greatest
teachers are people I've never met this
is people that I follow from Twitter and
books and podcasts and YouTube they've
made the biggest impact on me you don't
you don't need to actually physically
necessarily hang out with everybody for
them to make an impact but like let's
say you listen to this podcast we
released two maybe three episodes a week
each episode's about an hour so you're
hearing us for two or three hours a week
that's more than most people talk to
their mom that's more than most people
talk to their friends that's more than
most people talk to anybody so
you bringing this conversation into your
world is changing the type of
conversations that you're having you
start to change your conversations it'll
change your thinking change your
thinking it'll change your actions
change your actions you change your
results that's how it goes so um these
are the three ways that you can hang out
start to hang out with wealth
um there's one other one that I didn't
mention here which is when you hang out
with wealth literally you get around
people who've done what you did it gives
your imagination more food so when you
like I remember the first time I went to
a really rich person's house and I'm
like wow he's got a chef and he's got
like oh this this guy just came over
just did that for them oh interesting oh
they're saying that they travel once a
month to go do this thing and this
charity thing that they do that sounds
really fulfilling you know those stories
sounded awesome it taught me like how to
how to figure out what to even want and
what's possible what's achievable
because when you see it it's a lot more
realistic than just thinking about it or
hearing about it like you know beliefs
are good but an experience is always
better and so just hanging out with
people who already have wealth gives you
a sort of these all these like
subconscious cues it makes things feel
more realistic it gives you different
things that you dream about maybe you
don't care about a car like for me I
never cared about cars but maybe I
wanted uh like I always thought I wanted
courtside seats at an NBA game
then I saw a rich person with a chef and
I was like screw the game I want a chef
that seems awesome right healthy tasty
food that's being made by somebody else
saves you time that's that's
unbelievable so that's you know that's
the one other thing about hanging out
with money all right shift number three
going from small swings to Fat pitches
and I love saying fat pitches all right
so common mistake most people make they
take small swings like uh they take the
first good offer that comes their way
the first good job or the first good
deal they start too many projects at
once I've definitely been guilty of that
before uh they chase shiny objects so oh
I'm doing this thing oh there's a new
thing go over there
um you can do anything but you just
can't do everything this is a hard
lesson to learn in life you can do
anything but you can't do everything you
know um and the beauty of this is you
don't have to do everything so Warren
Buffett
one of the wealthiest men in the world
one of the best investors in the world
he missed the whole internet wave like
the last 20 years has basically been
dominated by the tech industry they
missed it that's all right he still
ended up doing great why because he
understands Coke and Geico his fat pitch
was companies like that that were in his
zone of competence things he understood
that he was able to act on and he you
can get rich anyway right the beauty of
it is you only got to get rich one way
you don't have to get everything right
you just gotta get one thing right to be
rich
um Ted Williams one of the greatest
baseball hitters ever he was famous for
waiting for the fat pitch he would sort
of map out the strike zone he said all
right all these are strikes but you
notice that you know when it's dead
center I hit 400 but if I try to hit on
the edge of the strike zone I'm only
hitting 230. and so what made the
difference between
Ted the greatest hitter ever and you
know the average or even above average
hitter was that they would swing at the
two you know the the pitches where they
would average 230 whereas he would only
swing at the pitches where he'd average
400 right that was his attempt uh to to
wait for the fat pitch and only focus on
hitting those and Warren Buffett takes
this even further for investing so he
says unlike baseball there's no called
strikes and investing you can literally
sit there and pass on 50 opportunities
straight just waiting for your fat pitch
and um and you know somebody asked him
you know what does a fat pitch look like
here's what here's what Warren had to
say about that he says if you look at
the stock exchange it's high you know
for the last 12 months will be you know
maybe 150 higher than the low uh the
lowest you know you know the low part of
the stock market he says all you have to
do is sit there and wait until there's
something really attractive that you
understand and you can forget about
everything else that's a wonderful game
to play in there's almost nothing where
the game is stacked in your favor like
the stock market but the problem is
people start listening to everybody on
TV or whatever talking or they may read
the paper whatever and they take this
advantage that you can wait for
something you really like that you
really understand and pounce and they
turn it into a disadvantage there's no
easier game than stocks but you just
have to be sure you don't play it too
often and that's the mistake that people
make they play too often they swing too
many times they don't wait for the fat
pitch and that's why their returns go
down
uh you know the first 10 years of your
career you probably don't even know what
a fat pitch looks like even if it was to
hit you in the face so my advice for
most people is the first 10 years just
go work this with the smartest highest
energy most resourceful people you can
find go into Emerging Markets or
exciting fields and just try to do
exciting work work with exciting people
because doing that is what's going to
train your gut to actually notice fat
pitches if you're doing that you're
reflecting consistently you're looking
back you're saying all right what did I
learn last year what looking back what
should I have actually been focused on
last year you'll start to learn oh wow
there was all these like opportunities
that were coming my way that I actually
didn't recognize to be as good of an
opportunity as they were
um and so you got to spend those first
10 years like that to hone your gut and
then after that you'll be able to notice
those fat Pages some common things about
like what is a fat pitch what does that
mean so like a platform shift like when
the iPhone first came out there's an app
store all of a sudden there was this new
computer in everyone's pocket and nobody
had built apps yet that was a fat pitch
waiting to happen anybody who jumped on
that like Instagram back then they were
able to do very well
Law changes uh so anytime there's a rule
of regulatory change that creates
opportunity uh if there's a new tech you
know technological breakthrough like AI
right now
um you know what people are doing
building on top of chat GPT or gpt4 uh
that's a fat pitch
uh Market panics so anytime the market
just panics and sells everything well
everything's on sale that's a good
opportunity to buy great companies
another one is working at a generational
company early on so if you saw Facebook
in 2004 to 2008
you could go in and be like look it
doesn't even matter that this is uh and
how much I'm gonna make off this you
just want to be on that rocket ship and
so there's one of these you know one or
two of these every decade and being a
part of them is you know that's a fat
pitch
the other one is when somebody owns
something but they don't realize what
it's worth you know they they have an
asset but they don't really understand
it fully or they don't have the right
lens but you do you know what you can do
with it this happens on real estate all
the time somebody's sitting on a
building uh it's only rented out for
this much so they sell it at a fair
price for what it's worth but another
guy comes in and says I know that I can
get a new permit to Zone this for
multi-family and I can build more units
on top and so he's selling it at what he
thinks is a fair price but to me it's
actually a steal because I have
asymmetric information
um that word asymmetric matters
asymmetric information is when you know
things that others don't asymmetric uh
upside is when let's say you invest in a
startup and a startup you know you
invest a hundred dollars the most it can
lose is your hundred dollars but
startups when they win they could be
100x or thousand extra turns that's
asymmetric upside you can win a lot more
than you can lose and so you want to
look for opportunities where you have
either asymmetric information or
asymmetric upside as a general rule of
thumb for how you how you invest now of
course
the likelihood of success matters right
like every startup's not going to 100x
or thousand X so you want to find those
where the probability of them working
and the upside make it worth doing
okay uh
the other part about fat pitches you got
to swing hard most people take weak half
swings uh they make a couple of calls or
they uh you know they send you one email
but they don't follow up or you even
give them an opportunity they don't
follow through
um you know don't just sit there and
just look or just bunt right you gotta
really swing and so winners follow up
winners double down on what's working
winners uh get on the next flight out to
go meet you in person and the way I say
it is intensity is the strategy most
people want the magic strategy the magic
formula
but unfortunately the hard thing to
understand is actually intensity is the
strategy most of the time the strategy
is pretty obvious it's pretty Cut and
Clear it's the intensity you take to it
that makes a big difference and so uh
once you find a good strategy you want
to execute it just violently versus
trying to wait for the The Perfect magic
formula Perfect magic solution uh
perfect strategy that that doesn't exist
um here's an example of a hard swing so
there's a guy Taylor offer I don't know
why he comes to mind but this is the
first one that came to mind uh Taylor
he's the founder of a clothing company
called feet now but back then he had a
merch business I think he was trying to
sell socks or something and it was going
okay but he wanted to double down so
turns up the intensity
he's like I'm selling merch I need
distribution what if I had the
distribution of some of the most famous
fine and YouTube stars that existed and
the top Vine in YouTube Stars at the
time were guys like Logan Paul and
a king batch and stuff like that he says
how do I get them to work with me right
I don't even know these guys how do I
get them to work are they so he's
watching their videos and he notices
that all the doors in the background of
their videos like the apartment doors
had the same handle and he's like three
of the viners have the same they must
live in the same building
so he hunts down he finds a building
moves across the country moves into the
building
and he knows how they like to work out
so he starts just working out twice a
day he's like this increases my odds of
crossing paths with him and they do
cross paths he tells them what he's
doing they get to know each other
eventually they become friends they
partner with him he becomes the first
guy to do merch with Logan Paul said
sells millions of dollars of merch you
know right off the bat he basically
leapfrogged where he would have been
with lower intensity without being
willing to Double Down
um and so I love that story because this
is a it's an example of of all the
things I mentioned right
um working smarter not harder uh of
moving towards the people you want being
near the people you want versus being
far away and when you see a fat pitch
Double Down swing hard at that thing
um so if you remember one thing from
this section it's intensity is a
strategy winners don't usually have a
better strategy is that they do the
obvious things with more intensity than
you do and the reality is you don't even
know what Max intensity looks like until
you see it you need to go work with
people who are real winners just to see
oh that's how they attack when they see
an opportunity or they have a problem
how they how they go and approach things
you got to kind of what I say I always
say is like you think the knob of the
volume goes only up to 10.
and then you beat somebody and they
actually the volume theirs turned up to
15.
and you're like oh now I know what
level 15 looks like as you have to see
it once and then it'll just imprint in
your brain
and so those are the three ships find
what feels like play to you and looks
like work to others find a way to hang
out with people who either have what you
want or are chasing it as hard as you
are and then take a simple strategy and
turn up the intensity yeah this book
probably has 50 other nuggets like that
but that's all for today if you like
this on YouTube leave a comment I'd love
to read them I'll respond to all of them
every single one from this video and um
yeah that's it that's all for the uh the
wealth uh the wealth wisdom or the money
wisdom master class for today thanks
[Music]
all right